this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by Skillshare home to
over 25,000 classes that could teach you
a new life skill
we rarely witness evolution on a
timeframe short enough for a single
human life to take notice these changes
usually occur over many lifetimes the
gradual drift of a creatures DNA to best
survive their environment but in one
case in the 1700s humans witnessed
evolution with their own eyes and they
caused it this metamorphosis coincided
with humans rapid industrialization we
began burning coal on levels never
before seen and its byproducts rapidly
changed the landscape for not just
humans but for the animals that shared
the planet with them the peppered moth
was one of those animals getting its
name from its speckled white and black
coloring designed to camouflage the moth
while it lay on lichen covered tree
backs the black variant was first
observed in 1811 many decades into the
industrial revolution at first the
mutation was rare but humans influence
on the environment grew and so did their
numbers by 1895 95% of the peppered
moths in Manchester had this black
coloring surely this black colouring
would leave them exposed making them
easier to spot for hungry birds in
reality these moths had adapted to be
harder to spot in this newly
industrialized world one stained by soot
and it may be time for humans to follow
their lead to evolve or die the rate we
have been spewing these pollutants into
our atmosphere has only risen since this
discovery our carbon dioxide emissions
have risen from 1,600 million metric
tons to 36,000 million metric tons since
1865 and despite our best efforts that
number is not declining human population
and development are continuing to
outpace our efforts to curb our carbon
dioxide emissions just as alcohol
producing yeast will eventually create
an environment too toxic for itself to
survive humans are pumping the world's
atmosphere with a gas that will
eventually render the world unlivable
for money if something is not done so we
have to ask ourselves now are we going
the way of a mindless single cell phone
guy that continued to poison their
habitat until they die
or are we going to recognize that the
survival of the next generation is more
important our previous videos have
discussed ways to mitigate climate
change by planting trees in the Sahara
or by using aerosols to block out the
Sun both are pretty extreme methods and
come with some big risks that could lead
to some unforeseen consequences instead
of some risky engineering tactic what if
we could just suck the co2 right out of
the air on doing some of the damage that
has been done well in certain
circumstances this is already happening
carbon capture and storage has been
around for years there are a few main
types of carbon capture almost all of
which happens at power plants capturing
the carbon that comes directly from the
plant in post combustion carbon capture
the co2 is captured after the fossil
fuel is burnt in this method carbon
dioxide is separated from the flue gas
which includes carbon dioxide water
vapor sulfur dioxides and nitrogen
oxides by bubbling the gas through an
absorber column packed with liquid
solvents such as ammonia in the most
widely used system once the chemicals in
the absorber column becomes saturated a
stream of superheated steam at around
120 degrees is passed through it this
releases the trapped carbon dioxide
which can then be transported for
storage
elsewhere in pre-combustion carbon
capture carbon dioxide is trapped before
it's diluted by other flue gases the
fossil fuel is heated in pure oxygen
resulting in a mix of carbon monoxide
and hydrogen the carbon monoxide is
reacted with water to produce carbon
dioxide which is captured along with
hydrogen the hydrogen can then be used
to produce electricity and the carbon
dioxide is stored pre and post
combustion carbon capture can prevent 80
to 90% of the power plants carbon
emissions from entering the atmosphere
this is a big deal the IPCC estimates
the carbon capture and storage has the
potential to make up between 10 and 55%
of the total carbon mitigation effort
until the year 2100 however this carbon
has to be stored somewhere it is most
often stored underground in a process
called geological sequestration which
involves injecting the carbon
into underground rock formations it is
stored as a supercritical fluid meaning
it has properties between those of a gas
and a liquid when carbon dioxide is
injected at depth it will remain in
supercritical condition as long as it
stays in excess of thirty one point one
degrees and at a pressure in excess of
72 point nine atmospheres many times the
carbon dioxide is injected into a
reservoir which previously trapped oil
and gas since those areas of natural
rock formations that help to contain the
carbon dioxide while this might be an OK
solution no one knows for sure what the
environmental impact could be if the
carbon dioxide were to leak out into the
environment in large quantities in some
instances leakage of carbon dioxide
underground has been shown to increase
plant mortality reduce growth and create
potentially severe localized damage to
ecosystems for this to be a viable safe
option the carbon dioxide would need to
remain stored for hundreds of years or
even indefinitely and the feasibility of
this is not certain other methods of
storing carbon includes sinking it deep
below the ocean at depths under 3,500
metres where it turns into a slushy
material that will sink to the ocean
floor under that amount of pressure but
this method is largely untested and
again there are concerns about what this
could mean for marine life and
uncertainty on whether or not the carbon
dioxide could eventually make its way
back into the environment there have
been more promising experiments in
carbon storage in Iceland where
researchers have shown that pumping
carbon dioxide into volcanic rock
underground can speed up the natural
process where the bath salts react with
the gas to form carbonate minerals which
make up limestone this is an encouraging
development but it has its limitations
it requires large amounts of water 25
tons for each tonne of carbon dioxide
buried meaning this process would be
limited to coastal sites another is that
subterranean microbes might break down
carbonate to methane another powerful
greenhouse gas and while 80 to 90
percent of a power plant carbon
emissions can in theory be captured and
stored in one of many ways what about
all the other carbon emitting things in
our world only 25 percent of global
greenhouse gas
missions come from electricity and heat
production at power plants
transportation general industry and
agriculture collectively make up around
60% of greenhouse gas emissions is there
a way to capture carbon dioxide from
these sources direct air capture has up
to recently been a largely theoretical
technique in which carbon dioxide is
removed directly from the atmosphere
theoretical because doing this on a
scale that would even make a dent has
historically been ridiculous pensive
some experts say as much as $600 per
metric ton of carbon dioxide for
reference a typical passenger vehicle
emits about 4.6 metric tons of carbon
dioxide per year but recently a team of
scientists from Harvard University and
the Bill Gates funded company carbon
engineering announced that they have
found a method to cheaply pull carbon
dioxide pollution out of the atmosphere
they say for as little as 94 dollars and
no more than 232 per metric ton of
carbon dioxide this means it would cost
between 1 and 250 dollars to remove the
carbon dioxide released by burning a
gallon of gasoline in a modern car and
not only do they suck the carbon dioxide
out of the air with the ability to store
it they will also transform the carbon
back to gasoline or jet fuel creating a
net neutral carbon based fuels while
this sounds too good to be true the
methods they use to pull carbon dioxide
out of the air is not too different from
what has already been done for decades
this type of direct air capture starts
with an air contractor this structure
wet scrubs the air by using a strong
hydroxide solution to capture co2 and
converted into carbonate the hydroxide
solution reacts with carbon dioxide to
form carbonate ions this occurs within a
structure which is much the same as an
industrial cooling tower the next step
involves a pellet reactor where the
carbonate ions react with calcium to
form calcium carbonate in the form of
dried pellets then a circulating fluid
heats the calcium carbonate pellets the
decomposition temperature breaking them
apart to release carbon dioxide as a gas
and leave behind calcium oxide finally
the carbon dioxide is combined with
hydrogen and converted into liquid fuels
including gasoline diesel and jet fuel
using the fischer-tropsch process this
is a process where a mixture of carbon
monoxide and hydrogen are converted into
liquid hydrocarbons these reactions
occur in the presence of metal catalysts
and typically at temperatures of 150 to
300 degrees this means the company can
produce carbon neutral hydrocarbons
meaning if you were to burn this fuel in
your car you would release carbon
dioxide pollution out of your exhaust
and into the atmosphere
but because this carbon dioxide came
from the air in the first place these
emissions would not introduce any new
carbon dioxide to the atmosphere and no
oil would need to be extracted from the
earth to power your car and perhaps most
importantly for the economic viability
of this idea they can sell the product
which helps offset costs allowing them
to capture even more carbon dioxide to
either convert back into hydrocarbons or
ultimately store and backing up their
cost estimates of between ninety four
and two hundred and thirty two dollars
per metric tonne of carbon dioxide is
the fact that they've actually tested
the technology in a prototype plant for
a few years in Squamish British Columbia
which offers a proof-of-concept that's
way stronger than simple calculations or
computational models it currently
captures and processes around one tonne
of carbon dioxide per day however for
this idea to work on a large scale the
process has to be cost effective to
implement cheaply around the world
without the massive cost of constructing
all new factory parts in the pilot plant
they pulled all of this off by designing
a factory based entirely on parts that
suppliers could already make cheaply and
by keeping careful track of their
emissions and costs at each stage of the
design and production process they are
currently seeking funding for an
industrial scale version of the plant
that will use low-cost renewable energy
that will produce 200 barrels of
synthetic fuel a day which they hope to
complete by 2021 but how much carbon can
they realistically hope to suck out of
the air in 2017 the world emitted about
32.5 Giga tons of carbon dioxide
if this technology were built at a scale
to suck all the pack out of the
atmosphere at 93 to 232 dollars per ton
simple maths shows that the total cost
would be between 3 trillion and
point five trillion that seems like a
lot but money industries are worth more
than that including Apple or the airline
industry definitely a tall order but not
impossible for this idea to work
globally in pulling substantial amounts
of carbon dioxide from the Earth's
atmosphere there would need to be
hundreds or thousands of scaled up
plants producing hundreds of thousands
of barrels of carbon neutral fuel to
drive down costs further in the same way
that solar and wind energy costs have
plummeted over the past decades with
increasing scales
however to keep global warming to less
than two degrees the International
target to avoid the most dangerous
impacts we will need a negative
emissions not carbon neutral emissions
we need carbon to be taken out of the
atmosphere and stored permanently or the
problem will only plateau indefinitely
and if carbon engineering is making fuel
from their captured carbon this is only
a Caribana neutral plan but the reality
of the situation is that when you are
only capturing and storing carbon there
is no market for that the only way to
pay for carbon being captured from the
air and stored on a large scale would be
government subsidies and to rely on our
governments to solve this problem is
certainly a mistake and a $100 per ton
at the moment there aren't enough carbon
dioxide buyers in the market for any
other uses to make a dent thus
introducing the idea of selling back the
carbon as a fuel is a way to fund such
an effort with market demand and money
coming in companies like carbon
engineering can improve their technology
expand operations store some carbon and
work towards making sure that less oil
is extracted from the ground over time
critics say that we should simply not be
taking the carbon out of the ground in
the first place
focusing on reducing emissions rather
than capture and storage or capture and
reuse and some worry the technology like
this will allow us to think that we have
no responsibility to reduce emissions
and it is cheaper to not emit a tonne of
carbon dioxide in the first place then
to capture it while these are definitely
valid points technology like this can
and should play a role in how we tackle
climate change it's unrealistic to think
that every industry every consumer and
every
in the world will change their behavior
in time to tackle the rising global
temperatures as much as we wish they
would and technology like this will go a
long way to help mitigate the negative
effects of the industries where a carbon
zero result is next to impossible like
steel or cement manufacturing or
long-distance air travel so this may not
be a silver bullet curing the world of
climate change but it is definitely a
technology to be invested in as a tool
in the toolbox to help solve the problem
and with direct air capture able to
operate anywhere in the world where
there is air water and electricity every
country could in theory have their own
supply of carbon neutral fuel in the end
we are not mindless animals who cannot
recognize the effect our behavior is
having on the environment there are
thousands of people working to solve
these problems associated with an ever
growing human population with hundreds
of startups using technology for the
betterment of humankind my audience is
full of incredibly intelligent people
who are more than capable of
contributing to fixing our problems so
if you think you have what it takes to
improve the world
you have probably thought about starting
a company you may not know where to
start with this course and Skillshare by
a New York venture capital fund may help
you it will teach you how to generate
and evaluate ideas for businesses while
giving you incredible insight from an
experienced investor on how to
successfully grow a startup
this is just one of over 25,000 classes
in a huge range of topics ranging from
creative skills like painting and music
lessons to technical skills like coding
with professional and understandable
classes that follow a clear learning
curve you can dive in and start learning
how to do the work you love a Premium
Membership begins around $10 a month for
unlimited access to all courses but the
first 1,000 people to sign up with this
link will get their first two months for
free so ask yourself right now what
skill have you been putting off learning
while project have you been dreaming of
completing but you aren't sure if you
have the skills to do it why not start
right now and sign up to school share
using the link below to get your first
two months for free you've nothing to
lose and a valuable life skill to gain
as usual thanks for watching and thank
you to all my patreon supporters if
you'd like to see more from me the links
my Instagram Twitter discord server and
subreddit are below
[Music]
you